viele bürger teilen eigentlich unsere
kritik am regierungskurs wir müssen nur
wirksamer gegen die herrschende
politische verleumdung vorgehen
wir können doch unsere politik so
vermitteln das ist schon in einem ganz
allgemeinen sinn für die bürger
nachvollziehbar zwingend wird und um
gerade auch im westen stärker zu werden
sollten wir die afg auch als
pragmatische partei des bürgers
positionieren wir müssen aufklären dass
grüne und die grüne cdu ideologie
getrieben sind und nicht pragmatisch am
wurde des landes orientiert politik
machen die afg hingegen die afg ist der
problemlöser
wir müssen die untere präsentieren in
den öffentlichen medien skandalisieren
und beenden unsere kampagnen müssen
strategisch umfassender vorbereitet sein
und wir müssen jene die verschreckt sind
vom medialen zerrbild unserer partei
einen weg zu uns bahnen denn wir sind es
doch die dem land seine verlorene mitte
zurückgeben und diese mittel sind wir
liebe freunde
wenn nämlich laut umfrage zwei drittel
der deutschen meinen dass man in diesem
land nicht mehr offen reden kann dann
werden wir diesen debatten korridor
wieder frei kämpfen und alle diesen
menschen eine stimme geben
ich will dass diese zwei drittel unser
wählerpotenzial sind ich will unsere
themen aus einer vier weiteren
perspektive aufrufen niemand schätzt
doch freiheitlich rationales handeln
mehr als wir gegen den wahnsinn
haftungsunion gegen die weltweite
öffnung der sozialsysteme gegen die
kopflosen wirtschafts vernichtungs
kreuzzüge der klima am basteln und auch
zur sozialen dimension der freiheit
müssen wir sprechen gerade bei den
gefahren der globalisierung sozial ist
es ein selbstbestimmtes leben zu
ermöglichen
durch schulunterricht wieder befähigung
vermittelt stadt niveauabsenkung zur
problem vertuschung durch einen
wohnungsmarkt der den bürgern nach
wohnkosten noch luft lässt zum leben
durch sicherung eines selbstbestimmten
lebens im alter wir müssen darstellen so
breit sind wir aufgestellt wir müssen
volkspartei sein und menschen aus ganz
unterschiedlichen erfahrungswelten
zusammenschließen den arbeitnehmern beim
autozulieferer betrieb der das
ideologische politik seinen arbeitsplatz
verlieren kann den lehrer in einer
klasse wo keiner mehr deutsch kann da
keine unterricht machen kann den
wirtschaftsliberalen der souveränität
und eigenverantwortlichkeit
zurückwünscht den niedriglöhner der
durch importierte migranten seinen job
verliert in bildungsbürger der um die
identität deutschlands fürchtet sozial
denkende die den niedergang vor ort
erleben wo rücksichtslos politik gegen
die eigenen sozial bedürftigen gemacht
wird in enttäuschten konservativen
flügel der union und die eltern die
sehen dass ihr kind in einer über
fremdelten klasse nichts mehr mitnimmt
an lernstoff außer mobbing und prügel
aldi möchte ich ansprechen denen sagen
wir dein anliegen ist unser anliegen die
afg ist kein problem lösen
wir müssen den menschen auch erklären
wir müssen sie warnen vor einer
dramatischen schwächung deutschlands bei
der verfehlten finanzunion der
migrationspolitik und der hochdosierten
energie und verkehrspolitik bei einer
verdüsternden konjunktur müssen wir den
menschen erklären darf man eines nicht
machen den wirtschaftlichen kernbereich
autoindustrie mit einer über
generationen erarbeiteten
kompetenzvorsprung und einer dichten
wertschöpfungskette aus ideologischen
gründen abwürgen
wir werden den menschen sagen wir stehen
zum steuerzahler gegen die zwangsabgabe
durch grüne und rocco die ersten unsere
schlüssel höchste zerstören und dann
strom und mobilität unbezahlbar machen
wir werden aufklären grüne partei der
besserverdienenden tugend pharisäer afd
problemlöser der bürgerlichen mitte und
des kleinen mannes meine damen und
herren
und wir müssen den menschen sagen dass
der demografische wandel schon jetzt
dramatisch sichtbar in kitas und schulen
nicht nur ein zivilisatorischer bruch zu
werden droht sondern langfristig auch zu
einem kippen der mehrheitsverhältnisse
führen kann
nur wir können hier die existenzielle
zukunftsfrage für das fortbestehen
freiheitlich rechtlicher verhältnisse
hierzulande und unserer über
jahrhunderte gewachsenen kultur diesen
wettlauf können schneller ausländer
eingebürgert werden die dann links
wählen unterlaufen die deutsche
schneller zur afg über diesen wettlauf
möchte ich für die zukunft unserer
kinder gewinnen das ist die
geschichtliche aufgabe der afd
die jährlich rund 50 milliarden die
sollten wir nicht ausgeben für illegale
migration sondern für familienförderung
da sind sie einzusetzen
wir müssen immer wieder den weg zurück
zum grund und geschichtlicher aufgabe
der afg finden wir müssen unsere
anliegen so zwingend erklären dass sie
als die mitte des politischen
koordinatensystems erkennbar werden wir
die neue mittel sind all dies möchte ich
eindringlich mit den bürgern
kommunizieren einheitlich diese aufgaben
ich würde das gerne für uns machen zum
wohle deutschlands
vielen dank gottfried kurios hier der
bewerber für den zweiten sprecherposten
der damit geworben hat klar zu machen
dass die auf die mitte der partei sei
ein paar minuten nachdem wolfgang g d
und gesprochen hat er auch immer noch in
der partei ist
die zweite frage von johannes huber und
die dritte frage von detlef ehlebracht
thomas gutwein mit der ersten frage 30
sekunden sein mikrofon
thomas
thomas gutmann mit der erste frage bitte
das dauert jetzt etwas der delegierte
das mikrofon findet 30 sekunden
thomas landesvorstand niedersachsen herr
dr
sie sind von fast von allen mitgliedern
als hervorragender historiker in der
partei bekannt welche weiteren
besonderen fähigkeiten können sie in die
arbeit in den bundesvorstand ein
dankeschön der antwort danke sehr
ich denke es gibt innerhalb unseres
14-köpfigen bundesvorstands eine fülle
von aufgaben und in diesem spektrum gibt
es sicherlich besondere spektrallinien
meine spektrallinien sehe ich in der tat
zunächst vordringlich bei der
kommunikation mit dem bürger um unsere
anliegen so zwingend darzulegen dass wir
die wechselwähler neu zu uns führen aber
es ist auch so als dass sich als
vertreter der unterschätzten weil club
mäßig eigentlich nicht organisierten
partei mitte gerne die partei
zusammenhalten würden ich sehe mich da
nach innen als ehrlicher makler bin
keine besondere strömung eingebunden und
kann so unvoreingenommen kommunizieren
in alle richtungen und orientierungen
zum wohle der partei wozu auch gehört
dass die besten leute aus allen
strömungen in die führung angebunden
werden nach außen aber möchte ich die
angriffe widerlegen und vor allem aus
der verteidigung heraus kommen und
unsere positiv
schonend dem bürger als seine eigenen
problemlösungen anbieten
dankeschön die zweite frage kommt von
johannes huber am saalmikrofon
mittelschiff ja ich hatte sogar mdb aus
bayern liebe gott fleht die wurde in den
letzten tagen vorgeworfen
du könntest nicht zugute organisieren
wie möglicherweise ins kino copala jetzt
möchte ich dich aber fragen bei richtig
im bundestag in der fraktion anders
erleben in allen arbeitssitzungen
bringst du durch konstruktive ein immer
mit fundiertem strategischem
sachverstand auch dazu ich möchte dich
fragen du bist der dak leiter für
unseren arbeitskreis inneres im
bundestag was der wichtigste ausschuss
für uns eigentlich darstellt warum frage
würdest du als ak sprecher für inneres
und auch nicht als bezirks zeichen
berlin schönefeld war dann würdest du
nicht abgewählt bisher verantwortet
die frage ist einigermaßen originell
vielleicht deshalb
vielleicht deshalb weil die
voraussetzungen die in dieser schein
logik eben vorausgesetzt sind schlicht
nicht gegeben sind
wir wissen alle dass im vorfeld von
parteitagen viele erscheinungen im
publizierten raum unterwegs sind und
diese haben nicht immer nur mit dem von
ihnen beschriebenen gegenstand zu tun es
mag sein dass damit manchmal auch andere
interessen verbunden sind
vielen dank und die dritte frage kommt
von hedl brach roten saal mikrofon was
sie sagen sie sind für uns mit gold
nicht aufzuwiegen sie sind dafür
verantwortlich dass die leute wieder
gerne bundestagsdebatten lauschen
aber wenn ich wenn es stimmt dann nutzen
sie zum beispiel diese mittel die sie
haben um ein mit einer mitarbeiterstab
im bundestag aufzubauen nicht voll aus
sie arbeiten da sehr autark nehmen sie
mir bitte die befürchtung dass sie auf
der anderen seite vielleicht dahingehend
ein defizit haben dass das die soziale
komponente um mitmenschen zu mitarbeiten
zeit nicht so aus so stark ausgeprägt
ist wie es sein müsste auf der position
für die sie sich bewerben kunden
verantwortet also der mitarbeiterstab
wir haben 26 leute bewerbungen geprüft
würzen eingeladen sechs mal ja gesagt
wegen verfassungsschutz geld krankheit
und manchen anderen dingen haben wir da
auch interessenten wieder verloren dass
es war es ein schwieriges geschäft wir
haben jetzt wieder zwei aussichtsreiche
kandidaten dabei wir sind dabei das
kontinuierlich permanent weiter zu
verfolgen wir sind gesegnet in unserem
ausschuss nicht etwa mit audrey sondern
mit lauter hoch effizient arbeitenden
kandidaten und
mds ich weiß dass alle die gerne
zusammenarbeiten wir sind ein hoch
effektives team das darf ich wirklich
sagen im arbeitskreis innen und es ist
eine erfahrung die ich mir in meinem
leben schon überall bestätigt habe ich
habe also schon chöre geleitet und mit
freien gruppen opern aufgeführt ich bin
mit teamleitung wohl vertraut und mit
größeren gruppen
ich kann das ich mache das als ein teil
eines 14-köpfigen wo deutschlands fertig
das ganz